mlb the show 21 it's brand new game
and it's out on both current and
previous console generations
so we thought we would compare the two
and see how they fare
and before you ask we've already seen
how the ps5
stacks up to the xbox series x since you
know it's a pretty big deal that the
show is now on
non-sony platforms but there really
isn't any differences to speak of
between those two versions
so instead we have the ps5 and the ps4
pro
but as it turns out there's really not
much differences between these versions
either you do get a nice smoother frame
rate
on the ps5 which is nice but visually
they are
pretty much identical i think that
that text over there way in the distance
it's like a little bit sharper
i guess it's kind of it however i see we
still have a few minutes left
in this video so uh i'm just gonna play
a montage of clips
comparing the two versions so you can
decide for yourself
i picked some music it reminds me of the
angry beavers theme
and uh that's why i picked it if you
enjoyed this video
please give a like and sub and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
brings the left-handed swinging andrew
benintendi
first delivery to him
starting to cool down a bit but still 84
degrees as we start playing tonight
oh and two the count to ben intended
well the key for him on the mound is to
keep the ball down
certainly hollow of the knee or lower
sinker change up guy
if he's gonna succeed against this
lineup he's got to keep the ball